chris and i i heard that you said you
would be jealous if you weren't cast as
abby in this film
so why were you so excited to be part of
this project
um well we've been saying it all day and
like the more i actually
think about it as a fact the more
surprising it is
that um this is technically the first
gay christmas rom-com backed by a studio
um i think maybe it still is the first
if you take
christmas out of it and i don't know how
thirsty it gets if you take raw more
calm out of it but i think it might be
the first gay rom-com between two women
that's backed by a studio um so that
like alone
was exciting for me because uh you know
it's really important to broaden
perspectives and hear from everyone and
like i can't believe that we're so late
to the game but
that's how it goes and uh additionally
i'm such a huge
fan of of clia i think she's such a nice
person and also
um this story felt really like
hers and authentic and
poignant because it it felt immediate
because it felt really true and
i wanted to help her bring that to life
mackenzie did you feel kind of similar
feelings you just this is
an important project but also something
that you just when you read the script
you connected with immediately
i think it was that i mean i i liked the
script first and foremost
i think something having a mission
statement is great but you have to
really
think the material is great and that
other people are going to want to see
the material when it comes out and i
i immediately i mean the the script made
me laugh out loud and it really moved me
and then yeah clia
as a friend of a friend of mine and i'd
heard just the best things about her and
i was
such an admirer of kristen's work and it
just seems like
wow you're ever going to do this this is
the absolute best condition in which to
get involved
so i i was i was really all in from um
when i first heard about it i was so
excited to be a part of it yeah
so i've seen a lot of holiday movies
this season and i have to say this is
easily one of my favorites
um and i like love rom-coms
um is it nice being able to put out a
movie in 2020 that
has a happy ending that is going to
bring joy to so many people
yes i was literally just thinking like
because we were all getting up to
do a press junket and i was like yeah
even actually we did like our long
lead whatever you know that doesn't mean
anything to most people but we had to
talk to a bunch of international press a
few weeks ago
and you know things are like kind of
tumultuous right now and
i was just like dude mackenzie our movie
is so nice
and easy to talk about because it feels
good and it's
it's warm and it's welcome and i'm so
glad
because it would be hard to talk about a
movie that didn't feel
like the right time to talk about it or
whatever and
you know things don't always line up you
make a movie it takes years to make you
don't know it always
like where and when it's going to fall
and i feel so lucky
to be talking about something like this
right now